ah look what we got back at the table mr
major garrett man hello yeah
no crying uh we got a crying in politics
i think some people do there are some
tears recriminations yes but no crying
we got some questions for you major but
let me frame it up for people here we're
going to begin with a rough morning
actually for president biden and
democrats after some stunning election
results republican glenn younkin beat
democrat terry mcauliffe in the virginia
governor's race and in the state of new
jersey democratic governor phil murphy
is in an extremely close race to keep
his job both states had been blue for
president biden last year so major
virginia in particular was a 10-point
win for joe biden in 2020 now in 2021
democrats couldn't carry it so in august
i went down to richmond for my show the
takeout i interviewed ralph northam the
governor i asked him two questions i
said is terry mcauliffe going to win
this race he said yes by five or six
points and i said how about this issue
in fairfax county and loudoun county
where parents seem displeased with
school boards either on transgender
policy what the curriculum is or
critical race theory said that's not
going to matter at all virginia voters
will not be distracted it's not an issue
at all
those declarations did not age well and
ralph northam didn't run terry
mcauliffe's campaign but he is part of
the overall atmosphere in democratic
politics in virginia they misread two
things one that terry mcauliffe was more
popular than he actually was and that
this issue about what school boards are
aren't doing and how parents either feel
empowered or disempowered to talk to
their school boards proved to be deeply
energizing across the board in virginia
i don't know if republicans can
translate that nationwide but it's an
issue to keep an eye on well isn't it
also that glenn younkin did something
positive and well on his own behalf by
threading the needle with president
trump between his base and then the
never trumpers who were turned off by
former president trump exactly he didn't
embrace him i was curious about that so
did that work clearly that worked for
him so those who were paying attention
the last couple of days say well we
didn't have trump have some sort of tell
rally yes so what happened there was the
younkin campaign looked at its numbers
and said look
former president trump can't deny us
victory and he probably would like to
take some credit so let's let him in
okay
tactically keeping an arms-length
relationship to former president trump
was essential for glenn young to keep
this conversation going in virginia on
these other issues not related to trump
so republicans can look at that and say
okay if you need the trump base to win a
primary use it but if you're in a
general election in a swing state or a
blue or purple state you have to keep
your arms distance from president trump
in order to focus on the issues that you
find or the voters that you're trying to
speak to find galvanizing that's exactly
what happened in virginia and new jersey
as well jack generally identified the
economy taxes and education down the
stretch those issues proved vital to him
and as we talked about at seven o'clock
in the 2020 election president trump
lost but lots of republicans won down
ballot center-right issues
absent trump center-right issues in this
off-year election absent trump proved
nominally
very successful this is the thing major
you were here yesterday and you were
saying everybody keep an eye on new
jersey if there had been a thought
bubble it would have said what you
talking about williams exactly because
new jersey it's a silly boy
that's right silly boy it seemed like
such a lock for murphy yeah who handled
kovitz so well what did you see or what
did you know that the rest of us didn't
that made my first clue in new jersey
came several weeks ago when former
president obama came in for a campaign
rally for governor murphy you do not
engage the former president unless
you're looking at numbers internally
that are ringing alarm bells and then
when the surrogate started coming there
it said to me the murphy campaign is
nervous about something they're seeing
either softness or a lack of enthusiasm
and that's really what happened in both
states for democrats they were less
enthusiastic in virginia and new jersey
so here comes the big conversations
going on right now in the nation's
capital yeah progressives are saying you
know what the problem was we didn't
produce things on the progressive side
of the agenda we let a centrist or a
moderate like joe manchin of west
virginia take our big bold progressive
agenda and continue to water it down and
didn't produce moderates will say no no
no
virginia and new jersey tell us that the
country's not yet ready for that
expansive progressivism and you better
dial it back and guess what they're not
going to resolve that today might be a
bit early but what does this say about
the midterms it says democrats have to
understand
that when they look at suburban voters
in lots of key states and places that
are
nominally democratic but not entirely
democratic and even places where they'll
appear safely democratic you better keep
that conversation going you better have
deliverable results that you can explain
and that touch people's lives absent
that a center-right agenda that doesn't
have president trump involved can
succeed can we just look at virginia for
just one second because people say
virginia's a sign of things to come to
your point about the midterms why
couldn't it be this is just what
happened in virginia doesn't represent
anything else the center of that
question is does the dc centric
political journalist clattering class
overemphasize virginia because it's in
the backyard yes it does
but it doesn't mean
when you look at that state you look at
something like ralph northam in august
telling me no terry mclaughlin's going
to win we've got this and when you don't
have it when president biden before he
gets on air force one says you know what
we're going to win virginia when i get
off the plane i'm going to see a victory
and he sees a loss that means you're not
seeing what's actually happening on the
ground that's a tell-tale lesson in
politics right politics they say it's a
blood sport and a little blood these
days thank you very much major